قالت القيد قيد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
في بيان الجيش الاوكرانيه مستمر في صد
الهجمات الروسيه على مدينه باكمود واضاف
البيان ان قائد المجموعه الشرقيه
اوليكساندرز
يوصل عمله في اهم مناطق القتال بجبه
باخموت واكد اشراك جميع القوات والموارد
التي تمنع الروس من تحقيق خططتهم للتقدم
على جبهات القتال في المدينه
وقال قائد القوات الشرقيه الاوكرانيه
العقيده
من الضروري كسب الوقت في باخمت لتكديس
الاحتياجات وبدء الهجوم المضاد في الربيع
واضاف على صفحه القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
في فيسبوك
لا زالت تحت سيطره قواته وقال ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تدفع بالقوات والمعدات لمنع
سيطره روسيا على باقمت واجباري مقاتلها
على التخلي عن تقدمهم